foreign
[Music]
welcome back to care for boys we're
indeed very careful boys and today Joe
has a question for Walter Joe take it
away I got a question because uh off
camera we were talking about Walter you
know doing the whole dating app thing so
I was like oh [ __ ]
you must have had different stages
obviously each you know like from from
like high school to whatever in dating
and like what is it like dating that's
different from now to like then and like
that's a great question yeah because
usually like I I'm assuming
like if you're when you're in your 40s
the type of people you have access to is
different too and a lot of people would
probably be like starting like families
or they're already on their like 10th
kid or some [ __ ] so like what is how is
it different like dating in your 40s
versus like your 20s and [ __ ]
that's a sad question is it well 20s
okay 20s is like I think more dating
wait what's that sound like
I mean you pitched a cop was like kind
of weird oh really okay so you know most
people already have their family and
stuff so like what's going on with you
no because because for me I see like 40
year old dudes that are like okay so so
let me Pitch it a different way speaking
that's someone who found their soulmate
wait wait
I just can't do it there's guys in
miserable marriages that wish to be
single too so then that's why I'm like I
don't mean why that's such a sad thing
not anyone here yeah you know okay I'll
tell you quickly from the 20s I think
you know like let's say one out of ten
they want long term
but like nine out of ten they just want
to like date and see what happens 30s
it's like more half and half if not 60
one like long term 40 and I kind of see
what happens so like in 30s they're like
rushing to get married rushing or yeah
but not everyone but most most everyone
in the 40s I feel like everyone just
looking for long term now you talk about
like the appeal to have families and you
know you kind of your passive aggressive
way of saying hey Walter you don't have
a family
[Laughter]
so one of the things on the dating apps
it'll say like half kids open to more or
have kids don't want anymore is that on
hinge that's actually part of like your
survey they'll yeah they'll have they'll
have it on there it'll be it'll be a
descriptor are you looking for one of
those I right now I'm on the fence like
even a year ago I wanted kids but now
I'm on the fence and the reason being is
because I watch a lot of TV yeah and so
I'm sitting down for a long time after
15 minutes of sitting down the same
place if I when I get up everything
hurts oh your sperm account is low hurts
that doesn't hurt so much
except it's not doesn't feel as good
yeah yeah if you know you know yeah
um so when I get everything hurts I'm
thinking if I have to pick up a child
like a toddler yeah okay everything's
gonna hurt they don't want to play I'm
gonna be like I'm gonna watch TV like
[ __ ] energy is like energy level is way
lower now and then also on top of that
let's say like the when the kid's 18
dude I'm like gonna be like
are you sure how old are you I'm 48.
you're not gonna be Kane old yeah
because like Kane's like 70 right now
yeah I'm talking about Undertaker's
brother right I'll be like I'll be 60
I'll be six okay if let's say I get
someone pregnant now yeah and then they
turn 18 I'm gonna be what 66. that's not
Kano is it I don't know not if you lift
and get strong yeah I do [ __ ] like
some CrossFit or something I thought
Kane old was like late 70s on yeah dude
yeah not at this game now I say Kano
because I had to use a cane last year
you're a cane old bro hey it does change
[ __ ] my next door neighbor just had a
baby like [ __ ] three weeks ago I I
used to me and him used to go sports
bars and we'll just watch games and [ __ ]
and that cat has dark circles on his
eyes it's [ __ ] deep as it gets the
first six to nine months is rough it's
wow but then it gets easier and easier
and easier he's like hey Steve you want
to go fishing today like I need to get
out of here
I mean it's new though like you said
yeah they gotta get into the routine but
then you never know you might have a
[ __ ] nerd-ass baby that just wants to
read books all day yeah that'd be so
cool make a little Brainiac I want my
kid to be like if I have a kid I want
them to be a nerd until like they're
like in college and all of a sudden
they're like NFL star yeah yeah
after one throw yeah would you get your
kid in the football because you're a
huge fan I would not you know the game I
would not get in there because the
situation yeah we not so all the chicks
that you talk to like which apps are you
on are you on like the traditional like
Tinder or they're more like long-term
relationships okay I was on Tinder but
Tinder
I don't care like honestly and I don't
know if it's true but it doesn't matter
what they put on there like I want long
term short everyone just assumes at
least in my mind that everyone just
wants to hook up okay it's like evolved
into that yeah that's the culture yeah
yeah that's why they made the other ones
and people are gravitating towards those
yeah so what are the other ones that are
more like long-term and Syria like hinge
uh Bumble coffee meets Bagel
um they're they're kind of more like
long-term oriented and I also think like
to answer your questions like even more
specifically it people in their 40s like
men and women in their 40s it's all long
term I I really there's no like hook up
[ __ ] no like out of like maybe like
let's say like let's say a hundred
profiles one may include like open to
Casual like but in addition to long term
so it'll be like open to long-term and
Casual like casual we're playing it cool
like the Casual can end up long term
yeah it can't it can't but but that
doesn't mean that the ones looking for
long term are only looking for long term
because they could be open the short
term term but they're just putting long
term but a lot of them like they're like
most of them I would say 50 to 60 of the
women will say I don't want uh no
hookups no one night stands No Scrubs
yeah basically no sugar baby situations
is it more um
not yeah I guess straightforward might
be the word but like when you guys meet
up for the first date like is there more
like straight to the point like this is
what I want okay I got to one of the
biggest differences between dating in
your 20s and 30s and 40s I found on the
dating apps is the straightforwardness
of like hey um I'm looking to get
married or I'm looking for a luck with
me long term I'm not here to mess around
and so the open communication I found to
be not only refreshing but way more
plentiful isn't that intense as [ __ ] it
is but when you but it is how people
play less games I think yeah you play
less games that's the thing there's no
games so there's no like oh like you
know um do you like me or like hey if
you do this that means you like me
there's none of that it's just like hey
like I'm running on top I'm gonna
[ __ ] die soon I'm [ __ ] baby in me
I'm on two kings lady pretty much it's
just like there's no there's no games do
you like that more you know okay like
there's I think mild games it's kind of
fun it's cute yeah however the under the
other end of the spectrum where there's
no games that's also cool and refreshing
too because there is no like oh what
does it mean when I don't text her she
doesn't text there is none of that like
if dude if she's not texting or you're
not texting they both know yeah it is
around you know yeah but like if you
guys are texting now it's we know
there's intention behind it yeah it's
not like oh I'm just gonna see what
she's doing or I'm gonna see what he's
doing like I'm just gonna text hey
there's none of that it's like
everything's been intention like hey do
you want to go out yes I want to go out
yeah rather than like do you want to go
out I don't know let me check my
schedule Oh but I don't have my calendar
with me really it's not on your phone
you know there's none of that yeah it's
all just I'll call you tomorrow yeah to
reconfirm yeah that's that's pretty cool
now and it's and it's also it works the
other way too hey you didn't call me or
text me so I thought we were off like I
thought we weren't gonna go out and like
I'm like that's completely Fair because
I should have I should have texted you
the day before or that you know so it's
just more responsible week
but it is it is because you get both
ends of the spectrum because
everything's with intent you you have to
this pros and cons to be very clear with
it my dad started dating um when he was
like I again when he was like maybe like
70 or something and he says like once
they go okay cool it seems like this is
like we're like have some sort of
chemistry like the first three questions
is are you in debt because uh if they if
he's gonna like it's a great question to
get together he doesn't want to assume
their debt the other one is do you own a
house because
um he doesn't want it where if they
don't have a house then if they come
over and live with him and they're like
let's say they get married if they get
divorced and they take half their house
yeah it's just like really like like
dude life is so dark
like six figure plus consequences you
know like it gets real like it's real
real is your dad still dating right now
he's trying to get get back with my mom
oh okay no because I have a piece I have
a piece of advice for your dad if he is
dating and if one of his questions is
debt he can get it and they kind of
getting married he can get a prenup that
would separate debt so if they get
divorced or if one of them if she dies
he won't assume the debt I see so the
prenup doesn't it's not just included
about paying money it's also about debt
more romance talk here yeah right that's
maximum romance and that's another thing
that's different when you're in your 40s
you should think about prenups
oh because by the time you're in your
40s everyone's got everyone being boys
and girls they both have assets
whether it's a car whether it's I think
assets and badges life you know
and then so people want to protect it
today's video is brought to you by Babel
all right check this out okay I know
that all of you guys in high school
probably skipped out on one of the
greatest opportunities of your lifetime
and that's learning a second language
for me it was espanol there's so many
Mexicans in Southern California that I
could have practiced with if I could
have taken the class it would have been
great and I love traveling to Mexico
it's one of my favorite countries and I
think I could have been better because
um I do hear like you know bits and
pieces of Spanish and like words and I
do pick it out but every time I'm out
there I feel like ah if only if only I
learn the language but now with Babel
that chance is back in my life again
yeah Babel is so easy to help you learn
another language because there are
instructions are only 10 minutes like
it's 10 minute lessons so it's
bite-sized it's not like high school we
try to cram all these chapters into your
brain and they are it's developed by
language experts so it's stuff that
you're actually going to use rather than
just learning like arbitrary vocabulary
words and with
choose from 14 different languages like
German French Italian they got so many
languages and what's so dope is they
have a 20-day money-back guarantee so if
you're learning and you're like man this
is not sticking I'm trying to do this
right I want to learn another language
but it's not working you can do it for
20 days and get your full money back and
right now you can get 55 off your
subscription if you go to babble.com off
the Record that's babble.com off the
record for up to 55 off your
subscription Babble language for live
they want to protect you know and then
also you don't want to assume debt
because if the Girl I'm dating has a
hundred thousand in student loans and
then it turns out like after three years
we had a divorce
the creditors could go after me
and when we're married it becomes one oh
wow so a prenup would also protect
against
um the debt why can't people just [ __ ]
yeah you can there's an app for that too
yeah there is I can live and enjoy each
other without all the extra [ __ ] yeah
people are crazy though dude people are
what's the is you've used Bumble right
yeah and that's the one where the girl
has to break the ice with you what kinds
of things do girls even see okay so
here's the irony with Bumble is that
when it started it was a great concept
oh women
um make the first initiating yeah it was
great guys like that's fantastic and
then what's the number one complaint
that women make against men when they
message them don't do one word like hey
yo and what are the girls doing Bumble
hey
Wow have you had any like cool responses
I have had one girl
um I'm not I don't do well in Bumble but
the one um because I'm Bumble we can't
write anything right so what is it is it
your profile is it like it's all is it
Like You Gotta Have a good pitch or
whatever photos and your profile thing
and so if they don't buy into what
you're writing they're not gonna message
you but like on hinge let's say I can
write something to them first and then
they can respond to it or not respond to
it you start to sell them yeah exactly
that's exactly what
Bumble you
know honestly this isn't much of a it's
not much of a pitch but if you're like
good looking a bumble so you'll get tons
of women messaging you can you upload
gifs so you can show yourself
but yeah but so like I have gotten one
message from a girl where she was like
this is so awkward I don't know what to
say and I thought that was really
charming and really cute because she was
very honest about you know like what her
deficiences were yeah vulnerable but
like most of the like most of the ones
like if I do get a message it's like hey
and then so I'm the one that has to come
up with something so there's no it's
yeah if you ever say anal you want to
sit on my face sometime this isn't
match.com it's not match have you ever
tried ones like like eHarmony with like
they got like uh High success rates so I
tried eHarmony years ago when there was
big National commercials on television
and then they would do free weekends
like on Long weekends so I tried it and
their their questionnaire is like 45
minutes oh it takes a long time yeah the
whole thing and then I've known like two
other people that have like really good
success yeah and the successors are good
so I was like okay let's just try this
45 minutes later I'm done and it says oh
now and then there's the little they're
telling you overlook fighting and
compiling your matches yeah because you
have no matches no way but that's also
the bank was way smaller before the pool
you're gay dude
you're on the wrong wrong setting Walter
sees it he goes and he goes man I guess
I'm gay the question there says I'm gay
now adding gay to permanent public
records no what the [ __ ] delete delete I
guess my favorite Disney princess was
Belle that's kind of nice and then
you're searching on the gay side and it
goes you have no matches what the [ __ ]
now I'm just screwed and then it's like
you're gay dude now I'm grabbing the USB
cables and I'm just like
have you thought about trying it again
or not no I'm on them now like I'm on
hinge and Bumble now oh okay he's not
re-upping on any harm you ever done a
straight up blind date I have for
Koreans blind mates are big wow you're
like setting up perfectly yeah yeah
so like okay
with friends I'm more discriminate
because some some people like they're
like oh you're single you're single you
guys should meet oh yeah I don't like
those those like it has nothing to do
with anything it's just that you're
single I'd rather if it's through
friends I'd rather be Oh I thought you
might have something in common with this
person because of blank she likes the
Rams yeah or something like that but she
likes to get butt
[Laughter]
Ramses
[Applause]
Esther she always brags about getting
butt ram that's the one that now I would
want to meet her like today you know
what I'm saying
um for sure but like if if when my
parents set me up I just meet them out
of like oh that's the worst time I stood
out of courtesy though because I know a
lot of it has to do with like it's their
friends so then rather than my my
parents explaining why my son didn't
want to save face for them yeah I'll
just go meet them I'll meet them and
like I've had dude I've been on some
decent ones I've been on bad ones where
like they've lied about me so like when
we part ways they'll go oh like um I
think one girl was like oh he just
wanted to go to a karaoke place with me
and I was like so my mom's like no what
like how did she get that we were
talking about where do you like to go
have fun and so she was saying like
where do you go and I was like oh
sometimes my friends go to like karaoke
places and we'll just drink there is
that supposed to be like a sleazy thing
no no she took it for some reason she
she took it my guess is she just lied
because she wanted to get out of dating
me again she told her aunt he wanted to
take me to a karaoke place
and like when I wanted a party like
wanted a drink and I was like what like
none of that was ever said out of my
mouth karaoke is not known as hardcore
[ __ ] bud no because it's like you know
like they call it in Korean but like
it's just you know private room like KTV
kind of Joy yeah and so even if I did
ask her to go go there it's like and my
mom was like he doesn't even sing like
why would he ask you he's terrible about
karaoke yeah that's pretty much exactly
what it is
weird you know but then like the aunt
was like you know what can he give her
another chance so we went out again and
it was just like okay but it was because
of the ant wanted it not because she
wanted it yeah
like she's she's physically she was she
was attractive oh wait it's just the
part I forgot so she accused me of
wanting to take her to a karaoke place I
dropped her off at a nightclub because
her friends were there
what on my way home I'm like I'll just
take you
so she's like but then she turned that
into does she does she have that
connotation with karaoke clubs as if
like you're just gonna try to because
you know they do that does happen by the
way it sounds like is so if she wanted
to go to the nightclub that means she's
ending the date but she probably doesn't
want to take that responsibility with
the aunt so I think she it sounds like
she's just going oh no it's because
Walter wanted to go to karaoke yeah
she's probably the responsibility yeah
but then but then my thing is how
short-sighted that is because obviously
the ant is going to tell my mom yeah
it's not like the ant's gonna go it's
not well thought out it's like oh she
didn't like him and that was it no she's
like oh well she was saying that he
wanted to take her to a karaoke place
and like drink with her yeah they can't
wait to talk about it yeah if anybody by
the way sees Walter at karaoke please
take a picture and [ __ ] tag it we're
gonna call this [ __ ] out yeah
what are you doing there
you know that the funny thing is I
haven't been to a karaoke place in a few
years actually because of kovid well the
prior to Kobe I just kind of like I
don't drink that much it's hard to sing
with the mask on are you talking karaoke
or karaoke do you know what I mean yeah
yeah uh I'm talking karaoke okay because
there's these karaoke places that where
it's basically fronts for prostitution
well that's a strong
word I would just say
prostitution light
because not everyone not because you
know not everyone does that yeah it's
far few between but like it's more like
uh Hostess hostess bars kind of yeah um
you'll look through a book you'll pick a
girl she'll come out sing with you
for a tip or something you could go
beyond the lyrics as they say oh it
could be on the lyrics in the United
States of America but in K-Town USA yeah
that's it you're Wild
[Laughter]
how does it get Anthony that was a great
idea
that's a great [ __ ] Voice by the way I
feel like that's why Anthony gets all
the [ __ ] yeah he does well because he
pays for it but yeah the karaoke but
when a girl says like karaoke place
that's not really what she means she
means like the karaoke place well that's
a weird thing to be upset about then
because that's actual just well maybe
it's insulting because she's a club
chick and she's like this guy want to go
to karaoke he might as well take me
bowling a piece of [ __ ] and that's
that's the other funny thing with the
with the club thing was that she was
sick she doesn't really go out that much
and drink but then her friends happened
that very night happened to go to a club
and was texting her the whole time and
she was like responding oh that's
another thing fellas fellas and ladies
when you're in a date don't don't text
with your friends unless it's to save
you like unless it's like hey I need an
emergency to get out of this date unless
it's that don't do that that's a
terrible thing or even hanging out with
their friends in general yeah yeah
because people get become like such a
habit of it and it's like oh dude Nick
we have a long time to go hang out and
then we're like hanging out but then I'm
still glued to my phone and you're not
really like well that's a bad example
because Nick doesn't hang out but maybe
you can try to
because Nick's already doing this
without us I've seen him do this during
Jiu Jitsu he's [ __ ] just like
I'm like hey what are you who are you
talking over there yeah
yeah so like yeah that's the blind date
thing so like with parents I go I just
go all the time friends I'm I'm more uh
discriminate
um but I actually prefer blind dates
better because it's just like you're
meeting someone there's no like judgment
until you get there there's no
prejudging you get them live yeah feed
judging yeah you're speed judging and
then usually usually you know pretty
much like if there's chemistry or
anything are you good in the room you're
good in the room huh I feel like I'm
okay I'm at least okay and then my thing
is if I don't feel chemistry I'm like
let's just have fun yeah like I don't
mean in a naughty way but let's just
have fun let's just like hang out be
friends yeah but there's some girls
they're not into that yeah so they just
they're just they'll sit there
that must be a drag that's it's really
hard oh yeah that sucks what do you mean
do they think like do you think they're
like are you trying to [ __ ] me I don't
you know honestly I at that point once I
notice no chemistry I don't even like
think about what they're thinking what
they could possibly be thinking about
but when they're just sitting there like
that I'm like I'm glad that we're not we
don't have chemistry because that means
the pressure's off yeah the pressure's
off and then you're not a fun person
right are you in [ __ ] mode though are
you like after that you're out back and
you're like let's get three blooming
onions over here
let's have fun huh
that attitude is what I have yeah yeah
like when I know there's no chemistry
because there's no pressure yeah um I'm
just like let's just have fun let's just
hang that's when you're at your sexiest
yeah
like eight place do you have a favorite
date place besides honestly yeah exactly
if there's no blooming onion yeah is
there a date place if I can't get 4 300
calories per bite yeah no my honestly
God the hand hand to God I don't know
which it is
um my favorite thing to do is eat like
crab oh I love like boiling crap boiling
crab or like go to a crab place the
reason being is because you have to get
messy yeah so there's no like print
proper yeah so that part of your brain
shuts down so it's more casual and it
feels casual and you can just start
talking because everyone's got crap on
their face everyone's got like greasy
like whatever steamy hands everyone's
licking their fingers do the same thing
take her to a Shabu place and say no
utensils whoa
so you guys got crab all over you yeah
and you you kind of mess but even with
boiling Boiling Crab it's like spice all
the sauce all over you and then maybe
this is why it's really it's not worked
out for you maybe this is why
once again your commentary is so
penetrated
he's just playing off of his I took the
beard at the end we got to get out of
this video
and that's why Leonardo has a 25 year
old age limit
[Music]
foreign